when do you know you found someone who
could be the one cuz I believe there's
lots of women in the world that I could
be with probably and have an amazing
life with but I was like when do you
know you found someone who could be an
amazing partner long-term mm-hmm
without a hesitation he said I believe
that each and every one of us has the
power within ourselves to create the
life that we really want and I want to
help give you the tools to make that
happen
I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense today I had an amazing
conversation with Lewis Howes I met him
back when I was promoting my book called
pretty intense I did his show called
school of greatness and it honestly was
part of what helped push me or
encouraged me and feel excited about
this idea of doing a podcast cuz I had
done a few of them that week and I was
like man podcasts are really fun it's
really fun to just dive into things in a
way that you don't get to do in a five
to seven-minute interview which is what
I was so used to so we got to dive even
further we talked for a really long time
and we touched on all kinds of things
and a lot of it for him had to do with
transitions and how he became this very
confident goal-oriented driven human
being but as a kid was super insecure
and even said I don't even know why I
was born which is just such a such a so
much distance between those two things
so we talked about bridging that gap and
how he got to this position of being
really confident and working for the
success in service as opposed to wanting
success in validation as a young man so
please enjoy this fantastic show
so did you get up at 5:00 a.m. this
morning for for 4440 so that you can be
out the door by 5:00 a.m. 5:00 a.m. I
went out the door and worked out at 5:15
in Barry's boot camp what's that like
I've never all red berries foods can
sort of fabio's
because you're just sprinting right away
and today's leg day and I started with
legs first and then sprinted but it's
only a 50-minute here's my thing my hack
is that berries I like doing group
workouts because it keeps me accountable
and it gives me competition do you feel
like that comes from sort of the team at
for when you were playing football and
in sports I like working on alone yeah
Aaron's the same way he he will at like
I'm the total self-starter all I need is
a goal yeah at a photo shoot
swimsuit you know something like that
like I just need a goal and then I'm
fine and I work out by myself most of
the time really yeah do you be doing a
lot of CrossFit yeah yeah I mean that's
see with group photos and quit I'll go
by myself but you'll work out with other
people there yeah but most of the that
Sohn Lee because I don't have my own gym
like full gym but I'm happy to go do it
by myself I used to have a big barn that
was a total CrossFit gym but not anymore
so so I but I I'm in total I'm 100% a
self-starter like I the other day I did
my own morning workout at like 7 a.m. at
the house just like running jumping you
know abs intervals and then I was like
the afternoon I was like well I have
time I guess I'll just go to the gym and
do where your actual weights now and so
my legs are but I did that by myself I
actually am yeah I'm a deep relation I
did a personality test and I'm a deep
relationship person and I'm uninhibited
in those would you want me alone but I'm
alone but I don't like like that's why
podcasts are fun to me because we're not
this isn't a surface conversation and I
have no time interest or patience or
energy for surface conversations so I I
did those personalities has to
superimpose as myers-briggs or no it was
called like our know maybe or something
like that what did they tell you about
yourself that you didn't know that um
that I am an introvert that I actually
oh that really I didn't really know that
iíve been told like you know Aaron would
be like you're just not really you know
you just this like not really social and
I'm like I ain't social I mean it's it's
yeah easier to look back and reflecting
like you're in a car by yourself all the
time
yeah maybe solitude of being like alone
self-starter like you like to go to the
gym with all your friends and I like to
just sit by my work too hard yeah I like
to have one accountability person okay
so I go with a component of mine who is
faster than me that's good that's good
always want to go with somebody less fit
I'm stronger than him he's 60 pounds
lighter so he can go the distance okay
he's got the engine I can sprint and
we're about the same sprinting you know
short distance but it went it's two and
a half miles and berries
after you do weights it's like a hit
workout my lungs are dead and he's sixty
pounds lighter I'm like boy vest on
yeah you know see how yeah it's me but I
like the accountability cuz he's always
pushing me yeah and that forces me to
wake up if I don't have someone to get
up at 5:00 a.m. yeah like I'll do six
true I mean I do work out people too and
you when you book a time you gotta go
you gotta go gotta go
the other interesting thing I found out
in the personality test was that because
it breaks it down into three categories
there's your social interaction which
and then there's there's so there's
three categories and within each
category there's your expressed amount
and then your wanted amount and so in
the social situation my expressed it's
like one to ten is like a one or two do
I want how much do you think you want to
hang out with no how much do you think I
want to hang out like socially like like
surface conversations so there's like no
zero it's a zero I want none which is
mice loners like want to be a lone thing
and then I'll ever be alone and have
your own long oh yeah conversations with
yourself yeah they're intimate and
vulnerable then service with people you
don't care yep I'd rather do yoga
meditate Journal listen to podcast you
know something like that yeah mmm-hmm
read and then the next category is it's
basically like your your leadership
so I express quite a bit like it's your
confidence it's your decision making
goal-setting goal-setting so I express a
lot and I want a lot like I'm very
actually don't want as much as I express
I express like a seven maybe and I would
want like a five or six amount so but I
express a ton of confidence a ton of
decision-making skills like I am what
they call choleric choleric all right
the first one I was like melancholy and
then the last category which was the
other one that I was in that was
surprised me was your deep relationships
and your affection category you
affectionate I am my love language and
the five love languages I'm
physical touch that's my number one for
sure and their woman's of affirmations
yeah that's actually yeah exactly you
know Aaron was like oh you're number
twos definitely words of affirmation I
think in my personality does it said
that I wanted to hear like and I love
you every day like once a day or
multiple probably every hours go yeah
yeah you love hearing that
yeah so my so the problem with my
affection category was that I express
like a six but I want like an eight Wow
so I don't express as much as I want and
so if you go like I don't know if you
ever like deal with people and go I'm
gonna give what I want right like a I if
I want affection but I don't really want
to express it I want to get it so it's
like this dichotomy of like confidence
to just kind of be like okay just just
give it it you know just like even
though maybe maybe I'm feeling insecure
but just go give him a hug or like go
just reach out and you know talk to him
or something like that in the affection
category but it goes with deep
relationships to why you why you scared
to give affection that I much as you
want to receive it I'm an observer it
says I observe and then react so if I
observe that see but then you'll give it
exactly so which is tough right so if I
observe that you want physical touch
let's say just the love language then I
give it but if I don't observe you
wanting it then I don't give it which
means I'm depleted because I want it hmm
so you got to know this about receiver
when you give it yes you're hugging
someone you're getting it right back
yeah so it was really have you ever
taken a personality test I have you have
taken a few I always forgive mine are
like the NFI J all those ones I can't
remember what my thing is but uh but I'm
my love language is physical touch and
words of affirmation that I'm always
attracted people who are like the
opposite you want like gifts or don't
care about it as much who aren't
affectionate sort acts of service you're
like I just don't want I don't care I
don't care either I leave my bed in ten
years
I'm a bit about every morning for me
that's really important I never used to
make my bed until like six years ago
okay never made it and then things
started to shift when I actually decided
that that's
one of the most important things I do
game J because it starts your day that
way I think it just it clears the energy
in my room as opposed to like coming
back to a messy space
I build inner confidence that like okay
I did something where I took care of
myself it's like an act of self-love
it's like I'm worthy of a clean
organized space sometimes it's messy
like around the bed but I try to at
least make the bed clean and I might
have stuff up in my dresser and I close
on the ground but it's like clean bed
it's just one thing I try to do every
day
it's not easy but I feel like I've been
doing it for six years now and it makes
me feel like yeah I'm I deserve to have
everything I want for whatever reason
when I make my bed it's like yeah I'm
deserving of all this what else do you
do for self-care I mean working out and
minimum five days a week for me is like
important yeah
and I'm very expressive with my words in
like a loving way so I've been dating a
new girlfriend for the last six months
now and luckily I've always dated girls
that physically they weren't
affectionate SC so I would she's like
more than a fact like super affectionate
so her number one and two are the same
as mine oh my god so we're just like oh
my god I love you you're amazing like oh
you're so hazy tanks are full full all
the time it's credible now she's like a
little messy though I like organization
too and she's like a little messy so I'm
enough to learn how to handle like
dealing with someone who maybe doesn't
do you know services macho things like
that but she's she's incredible I have a
solution cleaning lady well I have that
too yeah she's messy like at dinner
table she'll eat it's like just spray
everywhere in a black pet peeve of mine
oh my god yeah okay but making the bed
working out and meditation I think if
you those three things people talk about
it all the time when I read book in
podcast now but I think those three
things book bed and workout I'm sorry a
meditation bed and a workout is when do
you meditate right after the bed well
workout tell me what your what are you
doing sit on the bed you sit on a
charity lay down I said I don't try to
do anything crazy I sit up I have I went
to India
two years ago to become a meditation
instructor I went for two weeks and like
learns and then took meditation
instructor class and so I just follow a
simple 15-minute guided meditation where
I listen to some likes light music
that's kind of like waves crashing okay
and I have a process that I follow which
is just some deep breathing you're
really just counting you're doing a deep
breath in and then twice as long out for
four counts you repeat that twice and
then there's different processes where
you're humming some of it you're
thinking something to do a mantra and
then the ending is just a period of
gratitude it's really focusing on what's
the intention for the day yeah when I'm
setting my grip my gratitude for us so
if I work out first thing make my bed
usually I'll shower and then I'm
meditating I try to be clean afterwards
and then I meditate I feel my guy I feel
like I react less throughout the day and
I make better decisions by those three
things cuz I was like I'm deserving of
incredible things yeah how long did it
take you to get into that rhythm of
meditation because it's something that I
I enjoy but I have this all in or out
kind of personality with stuff like that
where I'm like if I don't have 30 or 40
minutes to really get there and feel
like I get you know messages from God
and or some from source and if I don't
connect with visions that I have and
have telepathy with someone or something
or send energy I'm like oh it's just too
much it's it's not worth it yeah one
after I did the meditation in class in
India I was pretty consistent for about
six months then I was like consistent
everyday consistent perfect I would say
five days a week and then I was like my
life is good I don't need this like I
can take a couple days off and it became
like once a week and then once a month
and then I started to notice that my
life went in chaos emotional world chaos
just like everything was kind of out of
alignment and so I was like well I
haven't been meditating let me try this
again and I started to meditate and I
realized I was less reactive because I
would in my meditation I practice
manifesting every day I want that day
and for the future but I also practice
what if
everything goes wrong today what is my
you're saying thought actually because
it's you know thinking about what you
don't want which is usually people don't
courage but but I think as an athlete
I'm sure you can relate to this
I would visualize all week long before
the game like how the play the plays
were gonna play out
I would visualize myself on the field I
would go on the field before the game
alone walk through my routes have a
dream about it okay but were you'd watch
Rudy
exactly I watched really a lot Rudy was
like and I would cry every time - I know
Aaron cries of Rudy doesn't he actually
knows the story real story so yeah I've
met the guy yeah it's crazy
yeah but I started visualizing what if
everything goes wrong who's the ideal
man that I want to be in those moments
hmm okay so if I was to look at myself
and see so I visualize it's kind of
weird but I visualize my ideal Louis in
front of me every time I meditate okay
what does he look like
what is his aura how is he standing is
he slouched is he tired or does he have
energy is he vibrant like who do I want
to become I look at myself like in a
metaphorical mirror and I think of what
would he do when everything goes right
so he's he cocky is he like showing off
to everyone is he saying I told you so
or is he humble and more of a giver and
what happens when everything goes wrong
when I get cut off in traffic every day
when I'm late to something when someone
does something I don't like or I feel
like someone was attacking me or abusing
me or whatever maybe taking advantage of
me how does he respond and I try to I'm
not perfect at this like I still react a
lot and it's an intention it's not it's
an intention but I want to you know I
believe that we can't control what
happens in our lives or what people do
but we control how we react to those
situations so if I want to become better
every day how do i how do I learn to
react better in situations when things
don't go well and how do I have more
humility and gratitude when things go my
way everything so I just try to think
about that and
and every night's a reflection like how
did i do on scale one to ten did I react
like a jerk and an [ __ ] again or was
I positive and loving and really
compassionate towards someone like
cutting me off or screaming at me or
leaving a negative comment on my pot
whatever it is it's like mm-hmm
did I step in their shoes and have
compassion or was I just reactive in
like a hurt little boy mm-hmm I think
that helps me grow into becoming who I
want to be hmm no that's beneficial so I
try to visualize it all which maybe it's
not good to like visualize manifesting
something negative but I think it's not
like I'm spending time I want to react
which is different than the bad thing
happening you're not visually
visualizing the bad thing happening
you're visualizing the man you want to
be in adversity yeah which is totally
different that's that's a positive thing
I read a book called frequency and in
the book one of the sort of techniques
that they had you go through was to feel
into the worst worst possible case
scenario of something happening and now
that feels in your body and then now
imagine the best possible case scenario
and see how that feels because again it
was all about energy and frequency and
it was so amazing the difference between
you know like receiving and digesting
and reacting to something in a really
like simple calm way versus getting
angry you're like oh that's awful
resistance yeah when your body tightens
up it's hard to focus on expansion
because it was our sympathetic nervous
system focusing on one thing or is the
parasympathetic I think it's right is
more of like a relaxed state sympathetic
I believe is a fight-or-flight and this
the parasympathetic is more like peace
and calm and so when we are when our
body tightens up we are actually
narrowing our focus and unable to see
the whole picture narrowing our focus in
the wrong way where an athlete gets into
the zone and narrow us a focus and isn't
flow this is like a negative thing so we
want to try to relax in kind of moments
of stress as much as possible I'm sure
you do this all the time in the track
when you tightened up it's hard to
freaking maneuver around people
well we narrow the focus to like block
out distractions but how do you so is
the meditation part of getting into the
parasympathetic system that feels even
more relaxed and call
for me it is and that's what all the
experts say because unless there's
another way for you to get into it yeah
us who want you know I'm I'm assuming a
lot of people are high achievers and as
us driven athletes who always want more
we don't take much time to rest our body
our minds and so unless we're walking in
nature for a couple hours a day unless
we're going on the beach and allowing
vitamin D to hit our bodies which is
supposed to happen a minimum of 30
minutes a day when we're inside all the
time unless we're actually peaceful in
our mind there's just constant anxiety
for most of us what I'm going to wear
it's anxiety but it's like content
thoughts of anxiousness stress worry
fear resentment guilt anger that's
running our minds which affects their
body and I think that's what causes a
lot of negative reactions for us
physically and when we manifest it in
relationships so for me when I do
meditation in the morning or at least
know that I did 15 minutes of peaceful
visualizing and calming my nervous
system relaxing my mind it gives me
confidence for the rest of the day even
if it's 15 minutes I can handle anything
that comes to me if I have an hour I'm
gonna be able to handle everything else
even better like two hours of meditation
wait I'm gonna be like a ninja like just
taking over the world you're levitating
Jay city does Jay city has two hours
every single morning does morning and I
and there's you know for me I mean this
is peaceful but there's a reason why
he's able to take on so much and he's on
the table on so much at so much all the
time and he's growing so fast and
everything he does I believe it's
because he is at peace in his mind and
it's heartless yeah as opposed to waking
up checking your phone already reacting
already go go go he's really taking in
the world he's getting his awareness is
expanded to how can I serve everyone not
just what's going wrong in my life right
now what I need to handle right now to
get out of the stress getting to you
getting more to you and who you are and
you can't operate when you're trying to
be someone else or react to everything
else how did you do that well yeah I
mean how how do you stay true to you
because I think getting to know yourself
is a lot more challenging
than the words it sounds easy you're
like oh I know me yeah how do I get to
know me I think I do a lot of
self-reflection and I asked for feedback
all the time from people I I think are
much wiser than me so I feel like I'm a
demand for feedback whereas my teens
until late 20s I didn't want anyone to
give me feedback I was like screw you
this is who I am don't try to change me
now I really look up to mentors of mine
and I asked them like what am i doing
that could I improve how am i messing up
where you feel like should I be doing
that and sometimes I don't like what
they say and sometimes it doesn't always
resonate with me but there's usually
something I can take and say you know
what yeah let me think about that better
let me try to apply this in my life so
I'm always a demand for feedback trying
to improve I think who I surround myself
with supports me and understanding
myself better they're a mirror of what's
working and what's not working for you
once you start understanding projection
and mirrors it starts to get really
overwhelming and you're like god I suck
it's all up to me but that's I think
that that for me like the purpose of
this show was to really wake people up
to themselves right to make people
realize that it's not outside of you
it's within you and if we all like
instead of trying to go out and say you
know change and save the world
go out and one at a time or just wake
people up to the fact that it's within
them did you ever have that moment where
you realize like oh [ __ ] that's what
they're me yeah yeah well my fault when
I was 20 almost 25 324 I read The
Alchemist Oh favorite and like the end
of the book is like the treasures within
you don't go look around the world
trying to find the treasure I think that
was pretty much the ending so sorry to
give it away for having read it but the
treasure was within you know I was like
oh wow I have all the answers I need
within me and then I started like asking
myself the questions now I'm a
professional question asker to everyone
else also now but I've always been
asking myself the questions
and I found that my intuition has never
been wrong never and I go I've gone
against my intuition a lot specifically
in relationships like I'll get into
relationships I'm like this is not the
right thing for me but something is
telling me like I want to talk her this
or I want to help this person I want it
I'm desiring this and then I stay in it
way too long and my intuitions like get
out but my head is like yeah but what
about this and it's fulfilling this need
and every time something doesn't work
out them and I knew I knew it wasn't
gonna work out my intuition is telling
me like why are you doing this so many
people are shooting themselves listening
to this right now they're like oh I know
what you mean yeah right it's shocking
how much so then there's this little
part within your intuition that gets me
confused which is past trauma oh yeah or
you know looking for a problem based on
that past trauma right because you want
to validate the emotion that you're
having because you've experienced
something in your past so I get a little
confused in that loop of intuition or a
feeling and / and and projecting or
letting some fear inside me get out of
control
based on something ever so do you feel
does that ever happen to you yeah time I
was just doing an interview yesterday
with a song a psychologist who was
talking about how we we'd look for the
patterns from you know childhood of our
parents to try to repeat that because
that's what's normal for us it's
familiar even if it was wrong that's our
mother screamed at our father all the
time or that our father cheated on our
mother or that our father hid our mother
or whatever it is even though we knew it
was wrong and it put us in a place of
stress our whole childhood or whatever
we faced we look for that in like that's
a partner hmm until we break the pattern
until we consciously say okay that's not
what I want even though it's familiar
for us so I don't know if you're smiling
because you saw this happen to you and
certain relationships in the past and we
repeat that I'm not a psychologist but
this is what
yeah what they've told me what have you
had to face that's really wrong man I
feel like yeah I feel like you're having
memories right now and I will see if
these are there some memory notes you
could help other people yeah you know
what's interesting it's like I got out
of a four and a half year relationship
at the end of last year and it ended
badly and I wouldn't say it ended badly
a Mayans from like reactions her
reactions were just like this was like
the biggest breakup in the world it was
the worst thing in kid of her hat was
like the end of the world right type of
unfeeling and I started to reflect after
a week of this ended I started to
reflect back on my life when I was like
what are all the relationships I've had
what do they have in common all the
women I've dated right thinking back to
like 16 17 mm-hmm
20 years of relationships I go what do
they all have a common and never once
after a breakup did I reflect back and
think what are my relationships have in
common I was always just like ah they're
messed up or it didn't work out or or I
messed up whatever I was just like that
didn't work out and I was like huh
they've a lot of them have ended where
the women have dated have I won't say
like gone crazy but just like reacted
over-the-top like freaked out make a
huge deal about like just cause a lot of
stress rated them too well that's true
though I treat everyone really well so
I'm like - it's not the guy you know did
anything crazy but it's like okay
I've always treated coming alone it's
like what is it well I'm the common
denominator so they've they've all ended
badly and the common denominator is me
mm-hmm
so I'm responsible for choosing all
these relationships for being in all
these relationships for staying in all
these relationships for all my actions
were everything okay my fault not
responsible so I finally had this
awareness like I'm responsible for
choosing to be in these relationships
well why are you choosing to be in those
relationships a credenza this is why I
said okay so what do they all have in
common right why did why was I attracted
to these types of women and I realized
that they they had a lot of things in
common but there are really three core
things that's just like I was like wow
how did I never see this before the way
it gets good so I think what before I
share this I think a lot of people don't
reflect on their breakups or reflect on
why they got fired from three jobs over
six years or reflect on why these
patterns happen yeah look at yourself
and I started you know took me 35 years
but I finally was woke up and I was like
okay let me reflect on this and I
realized they had three things in common
number one they were all beautiful to me
extremely beautiful I was attracted to
them sexually their beauty and more than
just like physical beauty they had you
know spiritual Beauty emotional beauty
mental beauty things like that so out
they were beautiful to me number two
they all had some type of talent or gift
that I was really attracted to one was a
talented photographer one was a doctor
one was a dancer one was a singer that's
just like wow this is cool like gift
that I can learn from and like play with
and like you know just like be
entertained by the third one I was like
wow they all have this thing in common
third one was a huge eye-opener for me
that none of them I would say in my
personal opinion believed they were
beautiful or talented and I remember
some looking for you to sell it I don't
know if they're looking for me but I was
looking I was like how do you not see
how beautiful you are how talented you
are I was like what you're so amazing I
was like come here like let me build you
up
let me like coach you let me increase
your confidence so I can be like the
hero for you or something right yeah I
was even thinking about this I was
subconsciously doing this until I
reflected back on and it's like wow I
would say again this is on my personal
opinion but I would say on us if we were
scaling like their level of confidence
one to ten I would say they were in the
two to three range most of them right
but they were so beautiful and talented
I was like man you're so smart you've
got a gift like you're unbelievable how
do you not see this but every time they
would get ready to go out you know
someone more different than others so
I'm not trying to like speak negatively
on anything but they just didn't see the
beauty they really Cod I just don't look
good I don't feel good I know this is
ugly I look ugly like they would just
say this language about their looks and
how they felt I was like you look
amazing
and it didn't matter how much I said the
words it doesn't matter how affectionate
the love language is that I were right
they would never I wouldn't say never
they would get to maybe like a five in
my opinion of like confidence like okay
they only talked about themselves about
half the time and after a while just
like man I can't keep doing this
yeah like after six once a year I can't
keep trying to like help you increase
when your confidence continues stay down
you've got to find this within ya but I
kept staying with people for years like
I'm gonna need you to listen to my show
though right you're gonna get luck I'm
sure they would say a lot of things
negative about me or whatever and yeah
I'm not trying to speak negatively I
think they have just like your
observation they have incredible gifts I
just didn't think they believed in
themselves
yeah I think as the the guy who wants to
help people believe in themselves more
and it was like how do you not see your
incredible gifts and I find I reflected
on I said okay first off I said I'm
gonna be single for a year you know I
was in a relation for four and a half
years up and down
rocky and therapy out of there like and
I was like I should listen to my
intuition the whole time and try to be
out of it right but I learned a great
lesson I was like moving forward when I
date someone I want them I want them to
be beautiful that I think they're
beautiful I want they have talent and I
want them to be super confident like
over the spectrum of confidence with
humility grace gratitude in a in a
giving mindset which I thought this
could be hard to have that's hard right
because that's perfect confidence that's
like just uh that's a piece right they
have these piece and every time where I
was in a relationship I kept saying to
myself man I never feel peace yeah there
was not one relationship where I'd come
home and I want to feel like like
clenched up when I get around them
because I just there's always gonna be
an argument or always a conversation or
doubt or insecurity and I was like I
can't keep trying to work so much to
have someone like increase their
confidence and I said to myself and I
remember asking Devon Franklin who
should interview sometime he wrote a
book called the weight where he and his
wife waited to have sex before they were
married
okay right they're both in Hollywood you
know it's a big thing
whatever wrote a book all the weight and
I asked them I go when do you know you
found someone who could be the one
because I believe there's lots of women
in the world that I could be with
probably and have an amazing life with
but I was like when do you know you
found someone who could be an amazing
partner long time mm-hmm without a a
hesitation he said when you feel peace
and I was like wow I've never felt that
in a relationship I've always felt like
drama stress chaos and it was also like
a model that I had growing up when I
reflect back on my psychologist who said
to me like my parents were always
fighting one was more confident the
other one was the breadwinner the other
one was like more insecure Wow there was
a lot of you know fights and then not
passive aggressiveness for weeks and
then coming back together and then
repeating that cycle over and over
that's kind of what I was doing in my
relationships was trying to find someone
who was insecure and build them up but I
wasn't even aware of it
I wasn't even cautious about it I was
just attracted to someone for no reason
we just repeat the cycle is hideous and
so I said to myself after the break
about like I want to be single for a
year I'm gonna join my life I live in LA
right you know I'm a successful guy I'm
gonna have fun I'm just gonna like keep
it casual and within a month this girl
like smacking my face and I was like
she's pretty much everything I've ever
wanted
Wow if it terrified me well you got to a
better place - yeah right we tend to
find someone we get to a place before
yeah right we're ready for it and you're
vibing at the same frequency and you met
someone like that and it was scary
because I was like I think I want to
jump on your better judgement exactly
like I'm gonna be this I'm exactly this
that she's idea she she just she may
need a no brainer because there's so
much peace mm-hmm wow I've never felt
that that's what I want you like that
was peaceful I go to dinner that was
amazing yeah it was crazy dare I say
peaceful so I think everyone listening
or watching should reflect on the career
they've been in where it maybe hasn't
been working out or the relationship
they've been in that hasn't worked out
or whatever may be reflected on like
what are the commonalities of all those
things yes ironically I just did
getting you know vulnerable and honest
with people did this similar thing with
Aaron where I was like let's write down
what we love about each others write
down what we learn to the other person
let's write down what's important for
the other person to do let's write
what's a you-know-what and then and then
one of the questions to FERPA both of us
to write down was let's reflect on on
how you've repeated cycles in your life
repeated cycles in your life what was
yours that you repeated oh let's go wait
I'm interviewing you I know but there is
now you know I'm I'm uh I have a dream I
don't look back I look forward so I get
very attached to a dream an image a
situation that I want to happen and I
have a lot of endurance for that you'll
go so I any years for that I I am I will
whatever it takes
sacrifice your life your energy your
time I will always move so I've moved
for every relationship so similar to me
I mean I've lived in Arizona North
Carolina relationships la I've only just
learned to like LA I hated LA when I
came I mean so there I've always moved
Green Bay I mean I've always moved for a
relationship and so I will always
sacrifice I will always be so all-in-all
I will and I will but I'm really I think
the hardest one is that I have so much
endurance and I will I will justify any
kind of behavior to save the dream Wow
so you'll stay in something that's not
working or toxic or hurting you or
whatever emotionally you're feel because
of the long term goal because I see this
vision which is beneficial in business
because you can hold on you know I've
learned how to flow because that's
another subcategory of like all of life
is this learning how to flow with things
which I want to talk about with you but
but that but the goal-oriented sort of
mindset that I have it just doesn't
really work in the personal relationship
category but I let it spill over how
them similar in the past but you know
it's interesting now I'm so I've never
been a hundred percent honest
relationship like intimate relationship
what do you mean like what like I feel
like you have to tell me exactly like in
my last relationship let's say I'll just
example like because all a lot of the
women I've been with have a level of
insecurity that's you know I would say
like below a 5 a level of insecurity
most of the time I'm not saying all the
time
a lot of them weren't weren't
comfortable with who I was in the world
yeah like if I was doing an interview
with you they would have an issue with
oh sure
look where is the interview how are you
gonna have a lunch afterwards like
you're gonna connect with this part just
like a level of like I don't have
freedom so I would just be like yeah
I've got an interview today or whatever
I wanted to say details yeah or I'm
having a coffee with someone I wouldn't
even say I'm having coffee you know it's
kind of like because I thought I would
do anything or anything would happen
it's just I don't want to deal because
it happens so often beginning I was like
this is not worth telling you the truth
about everything right when you're
nothing but you're freaked out you upset
your her you're frustrated just another
level of like insecurity so I wouldn't I
didn't have the courage and confidence
to tell the truth about those types of
situations because I don't want to deal
with the stress you can feel free I felt
peace free items I can be myself and
then I feel like she trusted me like if
you don't trust me you want stress if
you trust me when I stress out about
this so this relationship I remember in
the first few weeks of us dating
she was like I want you to promise me
something that you always tell me the
truth and I remember it sitting there I
was just kind of like smile that's like
I honestly don't think you can handle
the truth and she goes I can handle it
she goes I may not like certain things
but I can handle it and I go really
she goes yes I don't care what you're
doing your life like for that I don't
care what you do if you you know I know
you love to salsa dance go salsa dancing
and to do this like I will trust you
fully I just want you to tell me the
truth the lie is worse than the truth
it's worth it sucks and everything lot
eats it was never fun for me but I felt
and then I would resent the relationship
if I wasn't here but yeah I wasn't
telling the truth yeah the whole cycle
and so I remember I was like wow I had a
mom where I paused I was looking in
their eyes and I was just like okay I
will always tell you the truth
no matter what are you sure you want
that she said yes I go okay done and
it's been so freeing for me mmm every
moment I just say everything that's on
my mind like a radical honesty yeah even
though it is scary and takes time to
like learn how to do it like it gives me
anxiety telling her stuff does it cause
discomfort then at times - is there like
a little bit of tension every now and
again yes there is but she's not holding
on to it she doesn't make me wrong it's
only for like a short periods of time
where she's just like okay I don't like
that but she wants she'd rather me tell
her the truth
they lie and then we move past it pretty
I feel like it do you feel like you
almost have to do you feel like this
urgency of transparency between the two
of you where to go you can see when
something's going on she can see when
something's going on you just need to
ask you just need to say it I just need
to tell her
do you feel that kind of transparency
she has that more than me like she
whenever he does something she's like a
fiery latina so anytime there's
something on her mind she's like I
should just say how I feel all the time
I'm like I get it I'm like sometimes
like you might be like blowing things
out of proportion but thank you for
being honest with me yeah and now let's
move on mm-hmm you're not I mean so it's
learning for me because I've never been
this yeah I had I mean Aaron and I have
that super transparent emotion like we
can tell immediately I mean I could be I
can remember I remember being in LA here
we were leaving it was last year and
this is very early on and you know I'm
sitting in the car and he says something
and I just look out the window and I
start thinking something negative and he
goes what's wrong what just happened and
I was like what like that level of
transparency of immediate frequency fear
is immediate it's amazing it's a place
look it becomes a little bit of work
because you have to go there a lot of
work thank you a lot of work I think
it's a because it's it's easier to not
it's easier to not have resistance by
like not saying the full truth when you
know there's gonna be resistance by
sharing the truth who wants to feel
stressed no one so our defense mechanism
is to like not say sir yes or hide a
little Dan
yeah whatever might be to not cause
upset in a relationship especially when
it's constant upset which is what I what
I was feeling and my whole life I felt
like in different
areas of my life I was like a liar a
liar a cheater a thief like in different
times and stages of my life hmm I
remember when I was when I was a kid I
would lie to my dad because he was angry
when he knew the truth like if I said
the truth he would like spank me or
something I was like God you got taught
this from your subconscious has been
just everybody knew everything but for
all of us right all of us a hundred
percent I'm so wear it now and it's like
I'm okay I'm like I've like patted
myself as like a child on the back like
emotionally all the time I'm like it's
okay I understand you now and and I
don't beat myself up anymore for it I
used to beat myself up for for all the
bad things that I did and I would just
hold on and I would reflect this anger
into the world because I was like
beating myself up so as a kid I would
lie to my dad because he would get angry
if I did something he didn't like
so I'd lie about it then as a as I had
11 to 13 year old I I couldn't go into a
store without stealing something for two
years
every time I went into a store I had to
steal klepto for a couple years until
and I never got caught I was like not to
brag about stealing anything good
that's stealing now I was talking like
candy bars I got this daily myself be
good at Excel but for two years and then
I and then the one time I got caught I'd
never stole anything again and I got
caught actually by my dad we went to
hell we went to eat in LA now you're law
exactly I went to went to a client
clients house of his and I stole
something from the client and he found
out about it and I lied to my dad cuz
anyone in trouble and eventually like
found out about it and I was like this
is the worst feeling in the world like
haven't he made me go face the person I
stole from give him this thing back and
I was like I never want to feel this
again I've never stolen again and I
cheated on schoolwork all the time mm
caliber top copy homework I was again as
a was really good at it he is not going
to school but I was really good at
cheating and we used to have scantron
oh yeah totally so I knew exactly where
to position myself and the roommate
where the where the teacher was she
couldn't see like my eye level but you
order from you was a girl that had every
really smart girl and I would and I
would make sure I got a c-plus
I would not copy 100% I would like make
them wrong and it was just like a
professional
cheater I was a professional cheater and
I'm not proud I was like a defense
Mexican yeah I had study hall every day
I was tutored all the time and it didn't
matter how much people helped me when I
tried to not cheat I would fail so I'm
just like I guess I just have to cheat
if I want to pass this grade and when I
reflect back and all this I'm like now
I'm finally not lying
mm-hmm like even like little lies you
not I mean
yes like nothing like going to coffee
say stuff like that coming here today
exactly and it's like for the took me 35
years to get to a place I'm 36 now
between 35 years to get a place where
I'm not cheating lying Christie lling
and it's like I look back my god what a
loser I was to be like doing all these
things for so long now yeah I know it
wasn't like levels of lying or cheating
what it puts like but I take me back to
that kid because you know in obviously I
know you did you show I listened to you
but in doing like reading up on you even
more I was like wow your life has been a
series of so many transitions
yeah transitions and traumas yeah and
like one of them that was that really
identifiable as this you know this kid
who just didn't feel accepted you
wondered why you even were alive you had
no confidence and then on the other side
of us you turned into this very
confident goal-oriented I want to go to
the Olympics you know football player
and it's like take me back to that like
how did that kid who didn't believe in
himself and didn't even know why he was
alive how did he become confident there
were many days where I would get in
trouble at school and be in the
principal's office and I would just tell
the principal I wish I were dead like
over and over again and I think back
then they didn't know how to handle
someone who said those things I think
there's probably a protocol now when a
kid says like I wish I were dead
write to the shrink write something
right
there's just like okay get back out
there type of things and still paddling
back in those days that really pretty
close pretty close for some reason when
I was you know I was sexually abused
when I was five my brother went to
prison for four years when I was eight
and my parents were constantly fighting
and screaming and passive-aggressive it
wasn't a lot of love in the household my
older sister's attempted suicide so it's
just like felt like a it felt like
numbing small trauma every day and then
like big trauma every like couple years
right like something happened was like
boom here's a big trauma and then just
numbing passive/aggressive not being
seen her like cared for that that was
the story I would tell myself yeah
numbing little traumas big trauma and
numbing little trauma big trauma and for
whatever reason I kept thinking like why
am I here there's got to be a reason
because otherwise I monster just ended
that's what I thought as a child right
teeth and I just kept saying to myself
and I grew up in a small town in Ohio
and I kept saying to myself like I was
here to do something I don't know what
it is but I just mean to get through
this I just need to get through this I
need to figure out what it is there was
something inside of me that just kept
saying like you're here for something
greater I don't know what it was one of
a source of godlike my own craziness the
veil between intuition and you know the
intuition and you seem thin compared to
some yeah right to be able to be in that
position yet feel I'm here for something
that veil is thinner yeah which is great
and it took a long time because I I
really didn't feel like I had many
friends it wasn't until I found sports
and was just like I got picked last on a
dodgeball team one time in school and in
third grade and I was just like it never
again am I wow you're like six-foot oh
yeah probably 5 10 minutes I was tall
yeah I was like 6 foot then and that was
a pretty decent athlete I was like I
remember this I don't have you know
story but I had there was they took us
out and recess and had a the class do
dodgeball right and we're gonna split
the half the class into and the teacher
picked like two guys to pick pick the
kids yeah two captains yep and they're
picking one by one
the boys in the class right so they
picked all the guys first and I'm
thinking I'm gonna be when the first
people picked in my mind cuz I was a
pretty good athlete at this time all the
boys get picked and then they start
picking the girls oh my god and I'm
standing I'm like what the hell is going
on like I'm a good athlete right and so
they stick all the guys then they pick
one by one all the girls I liked an 11
yeah yeah ten eleven maybe oh my gosh
nine ten eleven somewhere on there maybe
it's cuz girls mature quicker I don't
know I don't know I was a tallest kid in
class I was like I thought I was a good
athlete whatever then they picked all
the girls one by one and then there's me
the last one and then even picked me I
was just by default on that next
person's team for whatever reason then
something snapped inside of me I was
like mother effers like yeah first off I
just felt like taken advantage of I felt
abused my whole smile life was like this
feeling of abuse and being taken
advantage of because I was sexual abuse
that's kind of the pattern that I've
found that I have to really like be
mindful of like okay if I feel like
someone's taking an advantage of me it's
okay like I don't have to react like
they're sexually abusing theirs right
not I mean it's okay
but that's kind of the story in the
pattern that I've that I've been in and
so something snapped and I was just like
I'm gonna destroy everyone in this
dodgeball and I was just like catch
everything the throwing in a kid's face
is I was like I would a DOM word it's an
SNL skit exactly and I was just like
never again will anyone choose me last
and kind of like you were I it's like I
had this goal in my mind and I was just
like I am after class or whatever was
done 3 o'clock every day I was at the
gym till 10 o'clock every night playing
basketball playing soccer playing
football it working out whatever I could
do I was playing a sport until I had to
go home because it was this deep dark
like desire to be something more than
picked last and I was like I'm gonna
prove every one kid wrong was ever made
fun of me who's ever bullied me picked
on me abused me I was like everyone's
gonna be wrong and that was the driving
force to me you know achieving every
that I did in athletics until I hit 30 I
realized like my whole life I've been
doing things to prove everyone wrong and
I think it's the second most powerful
fuel in the war
the most powerful is lifting others up
mm-hm and being of service and coming
from a place of inspiration rather than
meaning to look good be right right and
be the best mm-hmm
it'll get you far but it's the ego I
needed the win I need to be right at all
costs
and I was a horrible loser horrible
loser like no one can be around me
because I was just angry and moody and
when I realized like wow I've been doing
it all wrong it's gotten me far and
helped me make a lot of money and chief
athletic success but it's like why do I
still feel lonely inside and sad
especially after I achieve my biggest
year goals of 1020 year goals I'm the
most lonely why so I think these moments
of my life I really reflect and I start
to ask myself why am i this way why do I
feel this way after a situation after
I'm succeeding after I'm failing after a
breakup whatever it is why that's right
and I'm that's what my biggest lessons
come because if so many people blame
other people right they're like oh they
this they that we are responsible for
everything 100 but I've learned it and
when I take full responsibility for
everything my parents my the sexual
abuse the losses the wins the breakups
what are the good the bad when I take
ownership for it all even if I didn't
actually do it but if I take
responsibility I feel so much peace
because I don't have any wants to blame
mm-hmm I just accept it I don't say it's
okay yeah that these things happen but I
say oh okay it's happened and I've
accepted it what can I learn from this
where's the good in this and how can I
move forward and that's what brings me a
lot of peace yeah yeah you um there's a
quote that I liked you said our mind can
play tricks on us when we have no vision
a lot of tricks yeah well I think one of
scariest people in the world is someone
with no vision because they have nothing
to lose and they have nowhere to go
you settle for nothing it blows me away
I mean the amount of times I have asked
the question at just a simple
meet-and-greet at the racetrack over the
years or anywhere even at a an event
that I might be a speaker at is to kind
of look out there and say if you could
do anything in the world what would you
do
and so many people don't don't know
especially adults kids are like
astronaut yeah you know I wanna be a
football player you know but racecar
driver but adults don't lose vision ya
lose hope when I sold a business I think
like seven years ago around seven years
ago and I member asking myself like okay
I've got enough money for a couple years
it wasn't like tons of money but I was
like I can not work for two years and
I'll be okay yeah so what do I want to
do mm-hmm like it was coming this
question that a lot of people ask like
if money was no uh ya know if you didn't
need money what would you do right or if
you had enough well we got enough and I
asked myself that then I was like gosh I
really just want to like sit down with
fascinating people and interview them um
that's what you're doing and that's what
I've been doing I I feel like for me
when I've I've been fortunate enough
that anything that I dive into I
probably I do but but it's because I I'm
passionate the passion period like and
you work hard I understand you go on the
long haul yeah I don't care what it is
if I don't feel it
like I'm not like excited about it I
just don't do it exactly don't care how
much money you got I don't care what
like if it's not my who I am to my core
you know I just don't do it and so you
know it's amazing what happens when you
put yourself in that position of of
thriving and love and joy and and and
and so this is something interesting of
the feeling of that energizes you so
let's say these shows that I've been
doing it'll be a day where it'll be a
long day
a couple of them maybe they've been they
were deep and like I get done at the end
of the day and I am energized I am like
that was amazing I feel good other than
of course when I said interviewed David
Joe Dave Meltzer and toe Dispenza
had a migraine but I was energized I was
excited I was like pop in my head really
hurts from all that information but I
feel energized I don't know if you have
noticed that in your life where you like
you've noticed the energetic shift when
you're doing something that fills your
purpose and fills you up mm absolutely
wise absolutely and I think you know I
think it's easy for us to say these
things right now is I'm thinking of your
listeners there might be people that are
like well I don't have that
that a option to go do what I love right
now right now do you really believe that
to be true for them I'd like they have
to sacrifice something or give up
something they have in order gonna do
something I love for a while until they
can have more finances right so it's
like they may be able to go do what they
love and have no money
mm-hmm until they learn how to make
money around the thing they love so I
don't think it's I think they can do a
lot of these things just might take time
and that's why I was gonna say like I
remember in between college I spent it
took two years for me to get I was doing
like NFL Combine and tryouts that didn't
make the NFL so I had to sit out a
season then I did a rena league the next
season I remember during that time I was
like I have no money but I just need to
train to get ready for the next season
and I was truck driving for six hours a
day and was miserable oh yeah I was
making 250 bucks a week as a truck
driver driving from Columbus Ohio to
Cincinnati and back every single day oh
that's driving car NAPA Auto Parts some
Napa truck it was the biggest truck
before he had to be license to like
drive them on whatever the charts a big
rig yeah and it was like it only went 55
miles an hour oh my god the metal the
whole time literally down seeing
cornfields the whole time flat and
watching everyone pass me was so loud it
was uncomfortable I was like this sucks
it's not what I want to be doing but it
was a six-hour window where I could work
out in the morning and then afterwards
it was like the only type of Jeff
there's only type of job that I could
get right now and that was a balance
from the weekends and just doing odd
jobs here and there and I remember was
like this is not what I want to do but
I'm doing something else I love and
you're suing that so I'm going to do
this now and so I can make enough money
doing the other thing so I think there's
a transition phase for a lot of people
it might be six months might be a couple
years where they got to work on stuff
that they don't like how I was like
mowing lawns at a golf course and high
school I was like I hate waking up at 5
a.m. and doing this but it also taught
me a lot of lessons it taught me how to
do something that I hated and find joy
in it I think when you can find the joy
in mopping the floors or cleaning the
toilets knowing that whatever it is that
things you don't want to do then when
you find the thing you want to do
you're going to attract so much more joy
love and abundance because you learned
how to find joy in any activity I think
it's powerful so how long after you had
this unfortunate job that you didn't
love driving trucks and being a bouncer
did you break your wrist so after that I
played arena football I broke my wrist
in the second game of my rookie season
and then I played 14 more games with a
broken wrist
yeah so the X rated the doctor was like
here's the break Wow and I go I think as
athletes we're just kind of stupid we're
like well can i play on it you know a
weakness it's not something you're
supposed to show no physical or mental
and if I told the coaches they would cut
me because I'm arena football is very
cutthroat they don't you don't give the
whole season they're bringing guys in
every week and wow it's a great new
players in who are fresh every week to
practice against you oh this sucks
okay you're the only making a couple
hundred bucks so what I'm getting at is
that interestingly enough he kind of
weren't happy with playing football well
I don't know you were doing a job you
didn't like you're doing a couple jobs
he didn't like yeah you're like football
but it was super cutthroat but it was
painful but I had a bigger dream in line
which does make the NFL okay so I was
like I'm willing to stick this out for
the bigger dream but you had to be done
right you couldn't play after that so I
played the season and then I got I had a
surgery I thought it was gonna take like
six weeks it took six months - okay
so that was over with for football then
then it was over I was in denial for a
year so look now I'm gonna come back but
my arm didn't have any strength about a
year and a half yeah I would think so
then I started doing I was on my
sister's couch and for a year and a half
of my sister's couch making no money
feeling like a loser and just depressed
I was like what I'm gonna do with my
life my dream is over what do I do now
and that's when I started seeking out
mentors my idea actually my dad got a
really bad accident right then as well
where he was kind of my backup plan he
had a life insurance company he was like
when you're done living a dream you can
always come work for me so we kind of
had that in mind like I wasn't gonna
have to go find something if I really
needed it he would take care of me he
got a bad accident car accident was in a
coma for three months
still allowed today but he's never been
the same you don't really have an
emotional connection with him
and I was like wow my dad's not here to
support me I didn't have a college
degree yet because I left early for the
NFL Combine stuff and trainings and I
really had no skills because I had to
cheat all three or school all through
elementary school high school college
like I cheated my way through ok so then
what so I was like how am I gonna do
anything and who's gonna pay me for
anything is this when you came up with
the handball vision it is so I was on my
sister's couch 2008 Olympics China I
just got the cast off maybe like a
couple months before and I'm on the
couch watching Olympics because for me
the Olympics is always the ultimate goal
as an athlete that I've always wanted to
do but I was never playing a sport that
was actually in the Olympics right I was
I was playing football and I was playing
basketball but I wasn't good enough to
play basketball in lobbies and I saw
this and late a night like 2 or 3 a.m.
they were showing like the sports that
no one cares about in the USA and they
showed this board called team handball
and I was like where has this been my
whole life like this is my sports it was
unbelievable 40 million people play this
around the world how is it played it's
like water polo on a basketball court
this was opposed to water your dribbling
you're passing the ball you're shooting
it behind a net there's like a goalie
imagine like soccer with your hands
every possible corner it's super fast
it's extremely physical and there's a
lot of athletic power and speed and
accuracy yeah I was just like this is my
sport and I just became obsessed I just
had this vision in my mind I was like I
can make the Olympics through this
because I can make the USA team I don't
even know if the US had a team I was
just like I'm going to make this team
it's not a move in France exactly and I
started researching right then like us a
handball teams
there's no professional league in the
USA but there's amateur club teams and
there was a team in New York that was
like the three-time national champions
and I said I'm gonna move to New York
when I make money I'm gonna go learn the
sport I'm gonna make the USA national
team I'm gonna go play the lip
I'm gonna fulfill my childhood dream and
a year and a half later I started making
enough money when I moved to New York
City I couldn't get a hold of anyone on
any of these club themes no one would
respond to me to email nothing but they
had a website where their practice
schedule was in New York and so I just
said I'm gonna show up and just go there
one of these nights I show up on the
only American there it's all Europeans
who played professionally in Europe
who've now moved to New York because
that's where the games now all this is
gonna be harder than he thought
exactly and I said my name's Lewis Howes
I'm here to make the USA team go to the
Olympics and they just laughed at me
they're all talking like languages off
from their ass and I said watch me and
they're like well this is our last
practice of the season oh we just won
the national championships a week ago
we're just here to like hang out and
kind of connect come back in two months
I said all right tell me one show up two
months later and I'm practicing twice a
week because they were due to week price
a week twice a week for the next nine
months I make the USA national team and
play in international competition for
the last seven years and they just
played in a pan on games but you've got
to win the pan of games to go to the
Olympics and then a win so that's the
challenge okay if the Olympics is in the
USA then we'd been automatic qualifier
but it's not gonna be there until 2028
and I'll be 44 so my 43 so we'll see
keep working out it's been an amazing
journey like for me I'm okay if it
doesn't actually happen do you still
play right now I just played three weeks
ago in Brazil with the team yeah yeah
I'm one of the oldest guys on the team
at 36 and it's kind of like everyone's
like 22 who plays in sport and it's 20
to 20 so I was just in Brazil playing
against the Brazilian national team and
they're like in the world yeah wow
that's impressive and it's just and I'm
okay again if I don't achieve the dream
now but for me it's like why how did you
get to that point I wasn't at that point
until a couple years ago where I was
just like it's gonna be okay on any
dream I have I'm now okay if it actually
doesn't happen one because there's only
so much I can control so as long as I
know I did everything in my power to do
everything I
to make it happen yeah like the team has
to be amazing there's only one
tournament every four years you have to
win to qualify yeah this thing's out of
my battle it's tough and but I am okay
with anything in my life knowing that I
gave everything to pursue the dream in
my power and I lay it all on the field
like if I do that and it doesn't work
out then I can rest in peace and be like
you know I have no regrets so that's
where I'm at right now like any big
dream I have it's okay if I don't
achieve it anymore
I want to so this kind of makes me also
look at one of the other interesting
transitions that you've had which is
this tough athlete and then you step
into this role of vulnerability which
when you're in the tough phase the
vulnerability is the thing that is like
the weakness except when you step into
it you've realized it was the brave
thing to do what's the strongest thing
you do but you can't be how did you get
to that point I couldn't show
vulnerability as like a middle school
high school boy in my you know the way I
grew up if I ever wanted to be like hey
man I'm like going through some stuff
emotionally can I talk to you about it
they'd be like get away from me they
would like make fun of me they would say
derogatory names they've been equipping
a wuss whatever and they wouldn't want
to hang out with you so in order to fit
in you had to play the part you had to
wear the mask the mask of the athlete of
the you know whatever course you wrote
the book mastered masculinity which this
what makers realized yeah I think it I
feel like it was maybe like an SP bag
gift or it was some like I don't
remember where I saw it but I got the
book and I was like oh that's
interesting so what made you write that
30 years old yeah 30 years old I had
like another reflection moment I was
going through another bad breakup that's
okay look III would describe my life
like this you said it early on every
year this is every couple of years
there's something that happens in my
life I would never expect yeah which is
freaky scary and also very exciting this
is interesting I'm on the path to
getting better every day
it's literally like I don't even barely
listen to music I listen to podcasts I
listen to shows I
listen things are gonna help me grow
music is boring to me now that's how
that's how far it's gone for me so I get
it but it's also kind of scary
so you're 30 so I'm just I can relate
and I think it's a you should be proud
that you have those transitions
otherwise you're just otherwise it's
just you know status quo and that's
boring going through the motions yeah
feeding the pattern so that's exactly so
I hit 30 I go through a really bad I
moved to LA for a girl she breaks up
with me the day I move here after she
after she demanded I moved here oh wow
they didn't ultimatum which was already
a red flag and I already had knew my
intuition was off but I was like you
know I did stupid things my whole life
so it's all good but it was the greatest
lesson for me like moving here for a
girl when I said I would never move for
a girl was the greatest lesson that I
wouldn't be doing the podcast without
moving to LA feeling stuck feeling
trapped I was in LA traffic going
through this breakup I went through a
business partnership breakup and I was
just like everything was breaking down
it felt like I was stuck in traffic
after a few months in LA and I was like
why the hell am I here
like I hate LA I love New York City
where I was living
pursuing my dream of this Handball stuff
making tons of money I felt like on top
of the world and I moved to LA for a
girl I feel stuck everything's falling
apart and I'm trying to go like two
miles it takes me an hour right I went
the wrong time but how am I here why the
hell am I here and I started thinking
about self there's gotta be other people
that are feeling this as well who are
stuck in traffic everyone to look
miserable around me for this traffic in
LA I was like I bet people around the
world are like stuck in traffic because
I was walking everywhere in New York I
mean I didn't experience this I was like
I bet there's people were just stuck in
life like I feel right now and a couple
of my friends had podcasts and I was
like I wonder about this podcast thing I
wonder if I could find a channel to
create something to help people who are
stuck so I called my two friends who had
podcast right then this is in 2012
before podcasts were a thing yeah and I
was like tell me about this podcast
thing do you like it what's what's the
deal they were like I love it both I'm
sort of like I love it it's the most fun
thing I'm doing
like it's helping my business my brand
and I just I'm in love with it and I
don't know if these guys can do this I
could figure this out and right then I
was like the path I was like what would
it be called like I don't know I've just
always been focused on like trying to
achieve amazing things great things but
I've sucked in school my whole life like
I wish they taught these certain lessons
from sports and mentors and I'm finding
like in school definitely it's like the
school of like school right hill and
change the curriculum because exactly
right I think it's terrible well a lot
of it's pointless a lot of it
they don't teach they teach us how to
study for a test but they don't teach us
how to deal with our emotions when we
fail it 100% they teach us how to
memorize things but don't teach us how
to communicate you know lies things so
does that mean boid failure not be
successful
exactly so I came up with a podcast then
and during that time right after that
time I also like got in a fight I was in
a fight on the basketball court because
everything I was so used to when things
weren't going my way we reacting
negatively with anger because I didn't
know how to communicate my emotions I
don't know how to be yeah we hadn't
practiced express how I feel because in
school it was acceptable to when someone
upsetted you to fight them or to slam a
locker and be angry it was acceptable
because that was kind of the behavior
that you expected from someone like that
accompany young boy because every time I
tried to express my emotions I was made
fun of and laughed at and called a week
so I never knew I was able to and so at
this time business breakdown when they
should break down getting in fights and
just feeling stuck it was a moment I
said okay my friend was here at the
fight who works with me now and he was
like I don't to hang out with you
anymore
whoa he's one of my best friends college
football work together everything I want
to hang out was really massive I was
like wow my best friend doesn't wanna
hang out with me that's it that's like
time to look within you know what I mean
ya know what not everyone else is wrong
anymore
yeah it's time to look at myself and I
started saying I'm gonna shed all this
stuff I think it's hard for us to make a
change in a life unless there
some type of breakdown and the bigger
the breakdown the more we're able to
look and say okay what's working what's
not working I hate it's really hard to
change anything we have going on they're
gonna break through that's it and it was
kind of a perfect storm and I started
going to a lot of workshops and got
asked for coaching from a lot of people
talking to thier anyone I could talk to
who I thought could help me I would talk
to I would do their program and that's
what helped me finally start to break
down the walls it was like opening up
about all my traumas of my past and just
addressing it acknowledging it tall
friends order like a therapist I started
to like group workshops where I opened
up for the first time in 25 years about
being sexually abused Wow that would be
like pretty emotional yeah like I was
like I'm taking this to the grave I was
like no one needs to know this because
no one will love me if they knew this
about me right no one except me ever
don't think I'm a whatever I just made
up stories so I knew everything yeah and
so when I start talking about that I was
like and people actually accepted me for
talking about it's like wow like let me
just share everything you know that I
just like well that's gonna blow you
away but I was so scared to talk about
my emotions and I said man I don't wanna
be scared this anymore so let me do it
talk about it all the time until I'm not
scared and then I had power over all of
it well I was gonna just say you take
its power away
I took my power back like I'm from it
and listen I still get triggered every
now and then and things happen in the
Mike reactive but I'm so quick to do
like okay you're going back to a place
of scarcity or fear of insecurity and
that's not who you are that's not who
you want to be so I reflect on it I
address it I create a new commitment to
myself I meditate for workout make my
bed when I focus I'm just trying to be a
better person every day so is this your
own personal paradigm shift or do you
think that this is a more of a cultural
paradigm shift with Watto the masculine
and feminine both being acceptable
within genders either way I think it has
but I think we're being forced to I mean
I think men are being forced to be more
vulnerable and loving with me two times
up
social media with everything being
there I don't think men can hide this
kind of mask or live behind the mask
anymore otherwise they're gonna be
called out like everyone's being called
out for not being honest being
vulnerable being loving and and I think
you're just gonna constantly be called
out by someone you know the bigger you
are as a personality you'd be called up
by media or by peers your friends are to
call you out in smaller circles so I
feel like men are being maybe they don't
like it but I think it's the best thing
for men is to shift wearing these masts
into being more open do you like it
it's not comfortable opening up like six
years ago and I started like going
Gorillaz no I didn't like like talking
about this it was terrifying yeah it was
the hardest thing emotionally I've ever
done to talk about my biggest
insecurities because I didn't I
literally didn't think my family would
love me my friends I was like everyone's
gonna disown me if they knew this stupid
conversation that I built up but I felt
like everyone would think less of me if
they really knew who I was I think
anyone listening or watching if you ask
yourself like what are the things that
you've been through done resentful of
guilty of having forgiven what are the
things that you're ashamed of that you
don't want anyone to know and you don't
think and you think people would stop
loving you if they knew who you really
were write all those things down and
look at those things I think the
greatest gift you can give yourself is
to find one person that you really trust
and say hey I want to share some things
with you that I've never shared with
anyone and all I want to do is listen
it's very vulnerable for me to open up
about these things I'm really scared to
tell you but I love you and I trust you
and I respect who you are as a person
and I really just want you to know I
think if you write a list of things
you're most ashamed of and you tell
someone you really trust and care about
and maybe you don't have someone in your
life and maybe it's the therapist you
pay who has got to keep it confidential
at first I truly think your life will
start to transform when you share the
things you're most ashamed there's power
and saying words I don't know how you
know it was for you but in my life when
I've expressed something with words Lidl
yes but a ton of emotion pours out it's
like it's like that energy has been
sitting inside and when you get the
words out it literally pulls that out of
you and those in that negativity that
fear that you know those all those all
those emotions that you've pent up get
to go away not all the way but you get
to get rid of a lot of thickness and it
pours out of you with like crying and
like my biggest transitions have come
with realizations have come with like
almost like combustions like I'm shaking
yeah yeah vomiting some people throw up
some people sure that's probably
ayahuasca I think you thinking of but
that was that was last week
what's the thing that you were most
ashamed of to tell people and when you
started talking about it whether it be
publicly or intimately that you felt
this sense of like freedom or release I
may not we actually had just we were
touching on him like right at the
beginning but when I said that I didn't
really like like love racing that was I
didn't want to admit that to myself I
actually remember the first time I
admitted that to my dad at the end of my
last full season and I was like I just I
don't love racing he's like I know and I
thought he was gonna be one that would
be like what do you mean he's like I
know he's like you were good at it and
you needed a job and I was like wow wow
I mean I thought that was - it was 2017
how long did you not love it for I don't
think I ever truly loved write self like
I I never got excited to go to the track
even what the Berets day I couldn't get
excited I was nervous yeah I mean I
cared how it went deeply and there were
parts about it I loved for sure you
don't do something for 27 years and not
love parts of it but I was very very
determined to accomplish my goals right
I have the dream I want to accomplish it
I'm very goal-oriented Wow so it was
like but the process of it was you know
the growth that was the challenge I got
in love going to the race shop and
hanging out the meaning like there was
just a lot of stuff that wasn't so fun
and you know I didn't enjoy the
discomfort I got put in but gosh I did
grow and I learned to stretch myself and
I learned you know there's a lot of
things I learned but
saying that out loud my dad was probably
one of like the biggest moments I was
like wow really
and so admitting that out loud was
something that and coming to that
conclusion even like I can I can
remember being a kid and being like why
am I not excited to go to the track or
like as an you know getting paid
millions of dollars to go drive why am I
not excited to go to the track and it
was like I just wrote it off to the fact
that and maybe it's part of it is that I
was nervous right so it's hard to get
really excited I mean I get excited to
go on vacation right okay cuz I had to
go hit concrete walls at 230 miles an
hour and in there without me - yeah
so I was I there was a lot of that going
on so I can't just say that it was like
I didn't like it at all or I didn't love
love it but but I didn't get excited to
go and I was thought that was really
weird
Wow and now I know why and that's just
because it like for me there were parts
about it I loved but then there were
tons of it they just didn't care about
mercy for me I love like I love setting
a goal in achieving it so that it
doesn't really matter what it is and I
love helping set a goal that you loved
right you guys so that's kind of you're
a big buyer
yeah well that's actually what I told my
dad but momo's I was like if I did this
was something I didn't really love magic
what I could do is stuff I do okay if
I'm making millions of dollars and one
of the top of the world at what I don't
love yeah so interestingly enough like
this is something this is probably my
first like job I put air quotes around
it of doing these shows where I feel
like I love it
and I enjoy it actually I never did I
never did
I never studied or anything I did my
homework just so I get an A in homework
and the C on the test and get a B in the
class I wish I was that but I ever read
I didn't read stuff I didn't study but I
study every guest I have cool for a long
time I like format my questions like I I
mean I really go into it I maybe I'll
get a little bit more I would say half
of actually this interview has actually
been nothing about what I've written
because you're super interesting and you
can carry the whole thing but but and
we're very similar but you know this has
been something that I've truly like
fills me up and I enjoy doing and was it
about this
you love the process of interviewing
people and researching I love growing
learning the I mean school is done wrong
right we don't we should be climbing
trees when we're seven not sitting in
the same seat and raising our hand to
have to go to the bathroom right like
now we should learn I've taken more
courses and read more books in my 30s
than ever and so I think that's time now
you have kids I don't you don't wanna
have kids
oh no I do I mean I do you're gonna have
kids I don't know if I'm gonna have kids
but you want you I have frozen eggs I
guess I could happen on my own but but
uh but yeah but you have a desire one
day it's actually doing that I do yeah I
mean I think it'd be amazing to raise a
human you know world doesn't need more
people and needs more good people right
so do you want kids everyone asked me
that in my last relationship so I was
like yeah maybe in the future but I
think I never felt good about I didn't
feel peace in one relationship and I was
always terrified for the first time I'm
like and I talked about having kids
mm-hmm like in the future but I
comfortably yeah I'm like yeah I would
like four or five years you know okay
I'll talk about it comfortably it's far
enough away to talk about comfortably
but I'll talk about it oh man I can't
believe I'm actually having a
conversation about having a baby alright
it's so weird yeah in foreign to me but
yeah those normal no we're out that I
mean we're 36 I'm 37 and so you know
we've lived our let whole life without
it so it's almost weird to talk about it
now and I'm like it's so nice having
independence - yeah yeah like just be
able to do whatever I want it's just
learning how to be like okay my life
will be completely different and amazing
at the same time yeah welcome ages and
ways you never expect every couple of
years you never know right never now
move to three years yeah what can you
give me can it give me like maybe three
really important steps to to manifesting
because they think that you're you're a
master manifester and as I've heard used
to talk about like when no one's looking
you're you're you're scheming on how to
conquer the world essentially so like
can you be manifesting comes from first
gratitude for me it's just everything is
so simple but I just think it works
gratitude is
my whole day I heard wake up in the
morning and just say thank you and it
really feels good
thank you that's it the first thing you
do wake up it's not look at your phone
let's go to Grandma's thank you thank
you for another day and thank you for my
parents for bringing me into this world
and think you do my my ancestors because
they didn't have their life the exact
way it was I want to be here so just
that frequency of gratitude thank you
I'm here right and I have another day
any day I see so many people on the news
who are like yep he just walked across
the street and dead you know it's just
like you never know yeah when it's our
time and we think we have till a hundred
and we're gonna peacefully die or
whatever were their friends and family
can be gone on my way back home today
and so I'm constantly focusing on
gratitude and what I have is opposed to
what I lack so I think if you want to
manifest something you need to focus be
grateful for what you have as opposed to
what you lack that's for me the first
time what you want now what you don't
exactly so I'm always like man I'm just
grateful that I have that I live in LA
as opposed to other traffic I'm grateful
I'm in the center of the universe
essentially you know it's like where
everything seems to be we're the most
influential people I have access to
things it's sunny every day it's like as
opposed to complaining but the clouds
this morning like the sun's gonna come
out you know in the soon so I'm focusing
on what I have and I'm grateful for it
every day so me expressing that energy
I'm attracting and manifesting more I
think for me mine in my environment with
my thoughts is very important like
imagine my thoughts and my brain as like
a landscape and I think about do I want
to have don't want to have my brain be a
desert or a rainforest and a rainforest
things are flourishing it's being
watered with like clean water there's
animals there's fruits it's like
waterfalls it's like this growing living
thing and that comes from constantly
learning yeah constantly growing trying
new things and being in a positive
mindset positive mindset seems so simple
and people talk about it but if we have
like a buck
in our brain and it's filled with
negative thoughts we're gonna have a
desert not I mean if the bucket of our
brain is always filled with like
negative thoughts or lack or anger or
resentment or lack of forgiveness then
our than our environmental mindset is
going to be a desert nothing can kill
anything alive I think and growing that
so that's why it's like gratitude is
just such a ritual all day like when you
call my cellphone and if I don't pick up
I say thanks for calling tell me which
would grateful for mm-hmm and then I'll
reply so it's like I'm trying to evoke
gratitude from other people I'm trying
to think about it I'm trying to cause it
I'm just trying to be it mmm and I just
want to be in the environment of a
rainforest where things can grow and
flourish so that's what I really try to
focus on and I think healing the past is
another way to manifest like if we have
resentment in our art yeah it's really
hard to manifest like walls right its
walls so whatever pain I feel I'm just
constantly trying to heal from the past
I think if you want to manifest you've
got to let go of anger resentment a lack
of forgiveness alright and forgiveness
because it's hard to be great when
hanging at the same time so as I said
forgiving yourself which is really
powerful thank yourself just saying it's
just that simple act of like not
forgiving someone else outside of
yourself but forgiving yourself for
feeling a certain way or acting a
certain way yeah exactly
forgive us I've already forgive myself
all the time yeah the final thing I
would say is emotional courage I create
a creative challenge as my whole life to
overcome my emotional fears fears of
rejection fears of looking bad fears of
being judged and I'm always thinking of
I try to tell people this if they want
to increase their confidence write a
list not the shameless this is the
fierce list of all the things you're
most afraid of I'm not talking like I
don't know it's an alligator or
something you don't like the emotional
fears yeah I'm afraid of like my my wife
leaving me I'm afraid of whatever and so
my whole life I've been afraid
emotionally and at certain stages I just
say I'm sick and tired of feeling this
way I was always afraid to talk to girls
because I would get rejected by them all
the time and I never thought I was
interesting as like a kid as a gay
teenager and one summer I was like I'm
sick and tired of feeling scared every
time a girl walks by me go just be
scared yeah I was like I don't want to
feel this way mmm and I gave myself a
challenge this whole summer after I was
16 I gave myself a challenge in the
summer I was like every time I see a
girl it doesn't matter if I'm attracted
and not attracted I'm gonna go up to her
and I'm have a conversation because I
was so terrified to do it I was just
like I need to do it until it doesn't
feel scary yeah what's the greatest gift
I gave myself yeah desensitize yourself
yeah I was just like it doesn't matter
how many times I reject it I still love
myself mm-hmm and it got me just so calm
and confident next to a stranger
mm-hm the man-woman deserve anybody then
it got me confident to be able to just
like take a risk and say something silly
and goofy and just put yourself out
there someone like smile and it's just
like wow at the end of the summer I was
going up to like 20 40 year-old women at
a time and groups and just being like
hey what's up lady you know just like
being like a positive body goofy Wow
and like you did yourself there I was
like who cares what they say can never
see these people again but I haven't so
much more confidence like I was able to
get them to smile yeah we talked for 10
minutes yeah whatever there was a girl
he gave me your phone number you know
it's like okay little wins but it's like
yeah it helped me to like for the rest
of my life be like man I can go talk to
anyone the ability that to learn how to
say hello and goodbye are incredibly
powerful because sometimes the reason
why you don't go say hello is because
you don't know how to get out of the
conversation like I pride myself in
being professionally care goodbye
you know how there we go but hey what
you know I know you're in a rush but hey
it's good to see you or like you know
you got to know how to say hello and
goodbye and that is gonna be a helpful
tool your whole life exactly so that was
a challenge I remember when I graduated
college I was terrified to speak in
front of class my whole life it smells
like I'm sick and tired of being afraid
to speak in front of five people like as
I can professional speech right I could
talk to people one by one or small
groups like as a challenge but I
couldn't like to present an idea hmm
unless I was being silly or goofy or
something and I said and a mentor of
mine this is the time when I was like
injured and trying to figure things out
and a mentor of mine was like if you
want to change the world you need to
learn how to speak and present in front
of an audience I was like okay let me
try this out so I'm terrified to speak
but I'm gonna join a public speaking
class I went to Toastmasters I did it
every week for a year is that similar to
like I said when I was a kid someone
paid one of my sponsors paid for me to
go to the Dale Carnegie speaking course
it's probably similar I'm not sure what
groups and you do a little present -
exactly yeah this was learn how to
memorize people's names which I forgot
had to do but practice yeah this is like
it's an international organization you
pay like a hundred bucks for the year
and you they have like a an hour once a
week you meet for a session and
different people are giving speeches you
get people feedback oh wow you you have
opportunity to speak yourself and say I
did that people exactly and so I was
terrified I was like this 24 year old I
had a cast on at the time like a full
arm cast everyone's in suits and they're
like 30 to 50 and their professional and
unbelievable speakers I was just
stuttering the whole time I had to have
my speech written out word-for-word I'm
looking down the podium full-time
stuttering at my own words nervous with
what they're thinking about me but it
was a safe environment with like
positive feedback they're not just
laughing at you and I did that every
week for a year and at the end I'm no
notes getting standing ovations in front
of people but it's also like I had a
coach I practiced it in my mind every
day I would work on it every day I would
record my sessions I would watch them
back it was like being an athlete for
speaking yeah so I had this goal in mind
and I was just like okay my challenge
this took like it wasn't two or three
months like the girl thing when I was a
teenager this took a year yeah tober
come with fear well I have this as
saying for myself with difficult things
that the only way to the other side is
through through it that's it and it's it
just means that it might not
feel good it's not gonna fit it's not
supposed to feel good that's but if
you're gonna get the bigger the
discomfort the bigger the bigger the
breakthrough right the bigger the break
the bigger the breakthrough exactly yeah
so I try to do it everywhere in my life
that's anytime I feel emotional and
that's obvious like what I said when I
read more about shows like your life is
a whole bunch of just transitions and
challenges and yeah I think one of the
questions I even wrote down was like do
you feel brave because it's clear that
you have been it's just that you you
might not maybe you don't even recognize
that but you are to a lot of people like
you yeah
so on the way here I I I was like I
wanted to hear more about you and so the
perfect one listened to was 73 question
oh yeah that was great and a really
great idea in fact I I mean I think I
was also thinking myself what makes my
podcast any different than anyone elses
and I'm like me I guess you know write
my stories and what I've grown older and
learned and so but of course the one
thing that I wrote down on this card
while driving yes I multitask plenty is
of course that you don't get asked
enough of which is what are you most
grateful for so that's that's what I
want you to finish yeah I just have a
smile because not many people ask me
that what are you most grateful for I'm
always grateful for health and the
opportunity to use my legs and push hard
because there's so many people that I
know who don't have that ability and I
think we take it for granted when we
have all of our you know limbs and we're
healthy so I'm always grateful for that
but in this moment I'm really grateful
for you before you asked me to be here
I'm grateful to spend time with you I
think the last time we were together I
had a great time yeah it was really
great and I see your stuff online and I
think you're an amazing inspiration for
me let alone like tons of people around
the world but for me you're an
inspiration because of your courage to
end something that you were really good
at making a lot of money on to go figure
out the next chapter which might be
scary a lot of people like all you're
gonna be fine but I understand a
transition
it's scary yeah when your identity is
wrapped around something for so long it
doesn't matter how famous are good or
much money you make it's still
challenging so I'm grateful for this
moment with you thank you well
reciprocal because you don't you don't
maybe know but you've played a part in
it you know doing your show really
showed me how fun it can be to air-quote
work there you go I don't feel like I'm
working I don't either that's why that's
what air quotes around no you can see it
on videos you can see it least
imaginative Coralie but it doesn't feel
like that so thank you so much for being
here of course thank you thanks
everybody for listening to the pretty
intense podcast today I hope you enjoyed
it if you like what you heard today and
you want to hear more please click on
the subscribe button
you